[Music]
you're very convincing uh as uh as as a
badass we say we say badass in in in
this country uh a tough character um is
that
it and i was wondering in your past have
you ever gotten into a fight with
anybody do you have that side to you can
you
have you ever thrown a punch or you ever
yes i hate to say i have um always in
self-defense um
the last time was when i um
a [ __ ] which is a bum in uh in american
speak pinterest my bum which is ass and
americans speak and um i i punched him
in the face and then i ran out
and um ran up the street in hills it was
kind of comedy and then he sort of
lurched after me and it was
it was um
was he quasimodo
this is him coming at you
yeah and me tot like tottering along in
heels going ah i just punched a bomb
i like how you first said [ __ ]
no one has said [ __ ] in in either
country in 150 years i don't think
trump is trip trump is is is a bum no
but [ __ ] has the one that has the stick
with the little kerchief and they walk
along and then at night they make a
campfire and they do little dances old
school yeah yeah no no no that's what we
call them in in the uk
you call them bums and bomb is an ass
yes
uh
i went to another place uh we have a
clip here from hansel and gretel uh
witch hunters and
uh i believe this is a scene where you
uh you share this scene with another
bond girl is that right that's right yes
funky jensen um
yeah we never really spoke about that
but um yes we we even fight each other
there's a bond on one girl on
had that dream many times
i wake up crying uh
let's take a look at this clip from
hansel and gretel witch hunters
[Music]
gretel
the famous witch hunter
finally we meet
who are you
i see you got my invitation
say your name before my arrows rip out
your throat
i go by many names
none of which you're worthy
of pronouncing
[Music]
oh my god
[Applause]